With many of us home now, chances are your next interview will be done through a screen.
It's really hard to make that connection with the interviewer,...
...but one of the best ways you can do that is to present really well.
So ideally, you want to have a nice, clean, simple background.
Just a blank wall is perfectly fine.
You also want to think about lighting.
For example, if you have lighting behind you,...
...you could end up looking like a silhouette on the screen.
Ideally, natural lighting is the best,...
...so if you have a window that you can face...
...or a window to your side, that would be perfect.
Also, if you don't have a window to provide natural lighting,...
...you can resort to using a desk lamp.
And you really want to have your camera at eye level with you.
That way, you're not looking up at the interviewer...
...and they're peering up your nostrils...
...and you're also not looking down on them.
If you just grab a couple of books and pile them up...
...and sit the laptop on top of that, that is gonna raise it enough...
...to bring that camera right at the eye level for you.